Salut, ça va?
Ça va et toi?
Comme un lundi.
Tiens Romain,
merci de t'occuper de ce dossier,
j'en ai besoin pour hier.
Ouais ben on se tient au jus!
Je t'ai fait un mail.
Non mais c'est clair!
Bon, je t'envoie mes propals ASAP, ok?
Any questions?
Bon,
pour la vidéo de fin d'année
j'ai pensé à un truc,
on pourrait faire une choré sur Gangnam Style.
Whop, whop?
Ou alors un lipdub?
Encore mieux,
on va faire une parodie de "Bref".
C'est trop marrant parce que
le bébé panda il éternue,
et la maman elle a peur.
LOL.
Comment il va?
La pêche.
Et la banane?
T'as pas vu Les Goonies?
J'hallucine.
"La base des signatures de virus
a été mise à jour."
Bon ben ça, c'est fait.
Bon réveillon, à mardi!
A l'année prochaine!
Ça va?
-Oui, et toi?
Ça va.
Ben tu vois.